hey guys welcome back to brain Davey
Rebecca a monster on a world again today
we're just gonna go over this really
quick information that I just came up
with and I just found out on Twitter
basically I'm gonna be showing you this
one tweet and this from the Japanese
Twitter a monster on our world and when
translated it means that there will be
gameplay of behemoths shown at July 15th
this can also be confirmed by Eric's
gaming a very popular Monster Hunter
youtuber on the platform of course who
has made tons of great guides and videos
about the game and his tweet responses
the same exact thing that there's going
to be a glimpse of behemoth gameplay
probably somewhere on the monster on her
Twitter account around July 15th is
obviously going to be a very short video
but I just wanted to ask the question
that is basically what are you most
excited for in terms of behemoth are you
more excited for his design his armor
his weapons the new area how the
gameplay is gonna look or how the fight
will function I left to know your
thoughts in the comments below but like
I said super quick video to just let you
guys know they're gonna be getting a lot
of game play July 15th of the behemoth
and I wonder how he's going to play I'm
super excited to see the new area in the
elders recess and all the types of other
stuff that I just said beforehand so
with that like the V if we do enjoy
subscriber for new I cover the solo guys
for Monster Hunter World I cover
majority of the monsters most the higher
monsters also becoming behemoth as well
as well I also cover leaks tips and
tricks and the event quest every week to
let everyone know what to keep
up-to-date with and all that other good
stuff but with that my two most recent
videos would be on screen if you guys
want to check that out with that guys
hope we have a great rest your day
hopefully you enjoyed the video and
peace out guys